it's great to welcome to the program
today guy snodgrass who's a retired
american naval aviator who served as jim
mattis's speechwriter and chief of
communications
he is author of the new book holding the
line inside trump's pentagon with
secretary mattis
it's so great to have you on i
appreciate your time yeah thanks david
thanks for having me
so what was your understanding of why
president trump
chose jim mattis as his defense
secretary to begin with
well i think there's probably two
reasons i think the one and the most
important one is that
uh jim mattis has a great reputation
throughout washington and
uniform circles as well uh as i
understand it and i have some friends
who are on the transition team that
actually helped president trump and then
at that point of course president-elect
trump put together his uh forthcoming
cabinet
and uh like i said mattis has a great
reputation he's beloved in military
circles uh he's known as not only a
warrior but a scholar he's got
recent relevant experience so i think
that was hopefully the most important
reason but we've heard the president
himself say on numerous occasions he
loves
individuals who are straight from
central casting so to have someone who
had been a recently retired general who
kind of looks the part acts the part has
a lot of pithy quotes and sayings it
made him sound pretty terrific i think
is probably what really
swayed the pendulum over would it be
fair to say in your estimation that it
was not
the the position of jim mattis on any
particular
issue that was appealing to trump
i don't think that's the case i think
that you know if you think about how
president trump has operated with what
we've seen so far as you get into
you know year three of his presidency um
like i said he likes people straight
from central casting he likes people who
are gonna be be
unquestionably loyal to him and so
for jim mattis himself to have shared
publicly he said that when he went in
and he had his
interview first the role of secretary of
defense with both president-elect
trump and president-elect pence said he
had disagreed with the president and
every single question he was asked
that's an inauspicious start for a role
as one of the most senior members of
trump's cabinet so
i don't think there was certainly any of
his positions per se but i think that
again he's got a great reputation and
trump liked what he saw
what in your mind is it that made mattis
not the right
fit for trump in the end as we saw it
eventually it became very public
presumably that this was
noticeable privately before it became
noticeable publicly although maybe not
what what was it that made
them not actually as compatible as maybe
uh would have worked better for them
well i think it's it's interesting you
know even from my role working on
secretary mattis's personal staff
and anybody who's had that kind of a job
before you realize
job number one is protect your boss and
that could mean a couple different
things it could mean that you
helped shield your boss from anything
that might be untoward in the press or
you want to keep people who would be you
know sick of fans away from them
it also means protect your boss so that
you temper some of their worst instincts
or if they if they
want to lash out they want to do
something that wouldn't be in their best
interest you want to
help shore them up and make sure that
they don't inadvertently shoot
themselves in the foot and
and i think that's one thing that maybe
president trump didn't account for with
secretary mattis was that look he's a
retired four-star general he's
headstrong he
believes very deeply and doing the right
thing and so if president
trump had felt that mattis would just
blindly go where he pointed him
i think that's where that that distance
started to grow and like i share in the
book
as you get into the the winter of 2018
the spring of 2018 when tillerson and
mcmaster tillerson being then secretary
of state and mcmaster being the national
security advisor at the time when they
both walk out you knew that it was going
to get
pretty tough pretty quick the policy via
tweet stuff i mean one
story that has been relayed quite a bit
related to that
is correct me if i'm wrong on the
details but i believe that jim mattis
was out of the country and
did not know that donald trump was going
to be tweeting an announcement about
uh removing transgender military service
members changing the policy around that
um talk a little bit about that
and the more general idea of the policy
by tweet what was
was jim mattis's sense of that
well so you're touching on a couple
different things here one so to be clear
he wasn't out of the country he was
actually in washington state his
then mother who unfortunately has since
passed away but he was home visiting
with his mother
spending uh you know this is a guy who
dedicates himself he
is in the office about 12 to 14 hours a
day
really takes time off one of the first
times he goes
west of the rockies to take some time
off and suddenly here comes this
transgender ban
and the thing and it was tweeted as you
mentioned so the thing that really
was just so terrible about this from an
organizational standpoint is that
madison kept trump in the loop he had
kept secretary tillerson he kept
everyone who needed to be in the loop
uh with regards to how they were going
to one
research uh what the right course of
action would be what his recommendation
should be to the president per the
president's request then
the first time that it comes up boom
it's a tweet a series of three that just
completely reverses u.s policy
and more importantly mattis knew that
that would not stand
a legal defense instead of having it
underpinned by hard facts and
and expert interviews uh you just
suddenly change everyone's policy and it
wasn't going to stay on the test of time
and that was just one of many that i
highlight
as i as i recount the two years that
mattis had with secretary or scheme that
matt has had with president trump
uh you had the no noticed announcement
of the space force
uh creation you had the no notice
reversal of
uh the united states going to cease all
major military exercises with south
korea of course that's in the paper
again today
so that's one of the things that's been
so fascinating is when you look at this
two-year experience that i capture into
one book
you know people might say okay well
mattis left at the end of 2018 we're 10
months beyond that
things have changed they haven't a lot
of these same issues are still coming up
whether it's the troops at the border
the current negotiations ongoing with
north korea and of course south korea
and japan it was also in the news this
weekend
where japan was pushing back and so is
south korea about these
significant increases in funding that
president trump wants out of them so
there's a lot of things that just
continue
to reverberate so in the 10 months since
general mattis left
are there specific policies that have
been carried out that you believe
would not have been were jim mattis
still in his position
a that's a tough one right that's kind
of revisionist history there's a lot of
speculation there i do think though that
you would have seen
more pushback uh more and i don't mean
pushback in that
you would have a secretary of defense
openly defy the president he served look
secretary mattis
is a politician he took a political job
in order to be a part of the trump
administration so you can't step away
from that i think the
the concern though is that as you've
seen how the
you know president trump made a
statement when he was the
president-elect that he wanted to bring
the best people
into his administration the best men and
women he could find the most talented
and i think we've all watched as a lot
of those individuals who
stood by their principles rather than
blind loyalty
suddenly got pushed aside and so you
better know you know
in many cases there's been a second or a
third or even a fourth person in fact
secretary esper the current serving
secretary of defense
uh for the u.s military is the fourth
guy to have that job so
for that to have uh occurred in such a
rapid period of time there's no doubt
that
he's going to be more pliable when it
comes to fulfilling the president's
agenda and that includes what we've seen
with
sending troops to the border to using
military funding which is
crucial to rebuild america's military
it's crucial for
putting ships to sea and tanks out in
the field or for exercises
instead of using it to build a border
wall for example on the border with
mexico
yeah one of the things you know i i
share what some
uh on the left and some on the right
have seen as
sort of a renewed respect in a sense for
some of the main
people like jim mattis and rex tillerson
and others who said
this as far as we've come i can't in
short paraphrasing i can't do this
anymore i'm not going to do this anymore
i'm out
but at the same time donald trump has
been a known entity for so long i mean
the trump we're seeing as president uh
in the last year is the same trump we
saw as president in the first year
is the same trump that we believed would
be president in the transition period
and during the campaign so at the same
time there's a question of
what what what didn't they see at the
time what didn't tillerson see or what
didn't matter see is it as easy as
saying when the president
asks you you do it uh but clearly that's
not the case because ultimately there
was a limit to that so that's where i
sort of start to get confused
why was anybody so surprised that this
is the way it went
you know i think that you could
certainly say
and i i don't think anybody needs to be
forgiven per se it's just a turn of
phrase but you could be forgiven for
saying
that um when you have president-elect
trump
he is new on the political stage
relatively speaking i mean everyone knew
he's a land developer from new york
uh people had seen you know trump stakes
trump water or taj mahal i mean all
these things he's done throughout his
career
but there's i'm sure everyone had a
little bit of a candle of hope that when
he came into the office
he would be different um and he would
listen to these
men and women who are the experts who
spent uh decades and they've dedicated
in some cases their entire adult lives
to serving the nation
that trump wouldn't be deferential per
se but that he would certainly
adhere to or he would want to know what
their best thoughts were
and how could he use that to inform his
policy i don't think it went that way
and let's also be honest these are men
and women who are incredibly ambitious
this is their opportunity to make change
to have a positive influence on the
direction of
the nation the direction of the
departments they served and i have no
doubt
secretary mattis absolutely wanted to be
the secretary of defense
regardless of any concerns he had with
president trump because
it was his chance to help restore
america's military he cares deeply about
the men and women who serve and he felt
he could do
more good in the job than he would harm
and and i think we saw that for about
two years
the book is of course super interesting
and you detail a lot of interesting
discussions
which were actually the subject of some
controversy which i want to talk about
so if i recall correctly there was a
period of about
four months during which the book was in
the hands of the pentagon's
sensors i guess we would call them i
don't know if there's a more appropriate
or technical phrase for them
and uh you eventually sued the pentagon
saying they were stalling the release of
the book for no real good material
reason
tell us a little bit about that what was
the controversy around the book that
stalled it
well i think you know let's let's start
from the first principles if you will
every senior leader wants to determine
their own destiny they want to accept
the narrative
for how they're perceived and anybody
junior to them who may want to tell
their story
is a little bit of a threat and you know
you can look back through history
winston churchill i loved his quote
which was something along the lines of
that he
you know after following world war ii he
said that history would be kind to him
because he intended to write most of it
and i thought that was a great way to
put it so secretary mattis you know he
had written a book
about leadership that he published after
he left the secretary of defense
and i have no doubt that his time goes
forward he's going to want to continue
to set the narrative of what he
accomplished and the
and the great things that occurred under
his watch
my problem with that is that a lot of
times just like uh for example former
secretary of state henry kissinger
you know you have henry henry
kissinger's autobiographies which paint
one side of the coin but then you have
someone like walter isaacson who's a
noted scholar who comes in behind and
says hang on a second i'm going to do an
independent look i'm gonna do a
biography of kissinger
and share with you all the all of what
it looked like behind the scenes because
there's a lot to learn there and that's
the approach i wanted to take with my
book so
it was an a political approach it was a
chance to really take a look at the
entire two years that secretary mattis
has served
for president trump and you know it's
threatening to secretary mattis he
he can't control that narrative and
that's an uncomfortable place to be
so the pentagon sought to delay the book
they sought to block the book
and i think that they probably were just
a little surprised that i decided to
stick with the plan
or stick with the project and go ahead
and ultimately have to fight the
pentagon and to your point you know it
it was moving very swiftly until about
the beginning of june i mean
a month in the white house had approved
the manuscript the state department had
approved the manuscript everyone
external to the pentagon was complete
and then suddenly when mattis's own book
got submitted for review and got bogged
down then suddenly mine surprisingly got
bogged down too so
uh that all culminated at the beginning
of september where i filed a suit
and the department of justice knew that
it was going to be a losing case within
a week they had contacted me said hey
could you please drop the case we're
going to give you the book
that's interesting so you're there so
there were actually two things but it
sounds like maybe they're they're
related or at least you're suggesting
they're related which is
it being held up in the sort of
redaction or censorship phase by the
pentagon
but then if i recall correctly general
mattis
had questioned whether you were the
right person to be talking about
what went on but you believe maybe the
things are related in the sense that
the reason that the censors started
slowing it down was because
mattis had a book himself that he was
working on
oh i don't think there's much doubt
there i mean secretary mattis
you know i kept him look he's my former
boss
i have a great deal of affection for him
uh as someone who i respect deeply who
served the country very well and i
learned a ton during my year and a half
with him
in the pentagon but there's no doubt in
my mind i mean in january of this year i
had contacted secretary mattis to let
him know that i was going
to embark on this project then as we
reached the middle of march
i want to give him a heads up that we
were going to announce the book project
and he immediately took that email that
i sent him and forwarded it to the
pentagon to put the sensors
onto me so you know it's unfortunate i
think a lot of that stuff
tends to play out behind the scenes and
in my case i felt very passionate about
this project and
didn't feel that i should be bullied in
stepping away from it i thought there
and i still believe there's a lot of
information in this book that is recent
relevant and important for americans to
read about
like what really happens behind the
scenes what it's really like to be in
the room with president trump or
vice president pence or secretary pompeo
like these are
individuals of course who are still in
their respective roles today
you can read for yourself what it's like
to be in those meetings and make a
an educated judgment on whether you like
the direction that we're going or you
think there needs to be a change
yes and many of those descriptions are
fascinating to read we've been talking
with guy snodgrass who is not just a
retired american naval aviator who
served as jim mattis speechwriter and
chief of communications
he also wrote the book holding the line
inside trump's pentagon with secretary
mattis guy really appreciate your time
and and uh
you telling us about not only the
process but about uh your time
uh working with jim mattis thank you so
much yeah thanks david thanks for having
me